as joe biden finally lost faith in his
vp
after kamala harris botched nearly every
project the president put on her plate
it appears the white house pr team is
trying to turn the page
push kamala aside and beef up first lady
jill biden's profile they coordinated a
new puff piece published in vogue
magazine today
that claims quote the role dr biden is
fulfilling is in many ways
neither first lady nor professor but a
key player
in her husband's administration a west
wing surrogate
and policy advocate couple this with
reports that jill biden not joe
or kamala will be representing the u.s
at the tokyo olympics
we have to ask is she joe's new number
two
here to react her former white house
press secretary and host of outnumbered
kaylee mcinenny
as well as fox news contributor karl
rove all right carl i've picked up on
this
it does look like they're trying to
propel jill biden into a more
senior role at the expense of kamala
harris and you can tell she's
seething in the background i don't know
if you picked up on a photograph
last week they had a bunch of the
players in that bipartisan budget deal
go out to announce outside the white
house
kamal is kind of lurking in the
background
not really there just kind of lurking
off camera i don't know
what's going on what's your assessment
well first of all lots of first ladies
get vogue articles and let's remember
this is a
vogue article we're talking about new
york fashion magazine
so they generally do a nice story about
the first lady
they do a really really nice story about
the first lady if she's a democratic
first lady right and this one's over
this one's over the top you know jill
biden's
relationship to fashion seems to have
been complicated by the pandemic
she looks like a virtual goddess another
line
you know the way she was received here
was beyond touching
second of all this writer injects
himself into this story
in weird weird ways and right about
75 percent of the way through all of a
sudden i talked to joe biden on the
phone a few times once at their beach
house in delaware
the grandkids swirling around when
someone handed me a cell phone joe wants
to talk to you and then we're subjected
to
several paragraphs wow because i give
interviews i always invite the reporter
to my beach house
yeah exactly you know it's but it's not
just that though
kaylee it's it's that now they have this
profile and they're making her out
to be something more than your
traditional first lady like some
sort of policy wonk or power player and
i just remember that photograph
when she was over in air force one
flying over to europe and
she's at the big desk and she's working
and she's got all these notes while
kamal is down and
central america trying to figure out
what the root causes are i can't help
but think there's
there's got to be some sort of jockeying
for position here in the hierarchy of
the white house
seems that way an insider tip that
picture that was taken of joe biden on
air force one that was at the
president's desk i can tell you the
first lady melania trump never sat at
the president's desk
in his private cabin i mean that was
shocking in this article yes they
describe her as the designated driver of
that trillion-dollar covet relief plan
i don't know why you need a designated
driver we should have a president who
who doesn't need that who can control it
himself they also say
she's in charge of reimagining education
whatever that means we're doing a ton of
reimagining
while you're right kamal is lurking in
the background trying to remind joe
to bring up the tragedy in florida at an
event he clearly has multiple
handlers kamala won jill biden appears
to be the second
they called her the designated driver dr
jill biden of the
covid relief of a portion of it they
said abortion
okay carl you know we don't want to
disparage the president he's obviously
the leader of the country
but not so obviously because you you've
seen it
he even says it himself oh i'm going to
get in trouble if i stay and talk to the
reporters
he's obviously highly scripted have you
seen
anything objectively that concerns you
about his ability to to really fulfill
the role
of commander in chief no but there's a
danger in this article and it
starts where you started this whole
discussion namely that she
is a policy advisor look this is a
danger for the biden white house
let's say that you want to have a full
discussion of an issue and you figure
out that jill biden is on the opposite
side of the issue do you really want to
be the person in the white house arguing
against what the first lady is this is
why that's why
look nancy reagan was sensitive about
this go read what she wrote about
her concerns barbara bush was concerned
about it laura bush was concerned about
hillary clinton was not when i was at
the white house my office was formerly
her office
she was the first first lady to have an
office in the west wing
as opposed to just the east wing she had
two offices because
she wanted to send a message if there's
an issue that i'm concerned about
i'm going to be in my west wing office
which is big enough to have a conference
table
and have 12 or 13 people around the
table so i can be heard with where i
want to be on this
that was a problem for the clinton white
house talked to people who worked there
they were always concerned about getting
on the wrong side of hillary
if this is really true and i'm not
certain it is but if it really is true
that she is a presidential advisor
taking the lead on
infrastructure education and public
policy writ large
that's a problem no maybe she can fix
the border crisis
all right and i guess guys the the move
if you work at this white house
never disagree with the first lady good
advice never disagree all right
thank you carl kaylee thanks hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else